I want to give an answer to - okay yeah
because so far it was like how do the
discourse power affect the role like how
do I don't know how to discuss powers
affect how I choose to I guess identify
or like how I choose my decisions
related to language for example for
Mexico and I Spanish but at the same
time like part of wanting to be more
Mexican is like acknowledging that like
we have native languages that you know
like Spanish is the language that was
imposed on people who are from the land
of mix you know and like it's something
like because I underst the cause I wanna
like I don't know like get to know that
because I like it's not me that
motivates me to try to learn another
native languages I know but just because
I get feels like okay you know I need
in fact overseer girls
I think that really explains why a lot
of african-americans like see African
American vernacular English did
something bad
yes and that way we keep private a
couple of times you know in calling me
chastise for letting it slip out in
public like you know what do you think
of younger members yeah so you know no
don't talk like that in public and this
question speaks to the heart of that for
the first part I wanted to like we were
talking about like authenticity in
language but I something I want to
comment it something you like
speaking of language it's an experience
like just by the fact that it has like
different stories and like different
sayings and so like in some sense like
if you like not speaking a language like
in some sense I'd you're like for
example like this I'm sure the sort of
same thing Creole and Chinese I just
I've never will never be aware of
because I'm speak the language and that
is understand not experiencing them that
doesn't mean um that's authentic but I
just really mean said like like if you
like I cannot identify this because I
can have in that those experiences and
like it's not to say that that should
change how people identify but like what
I didn't know say is that like there is
we cannot ignore the role that language
for something like experience you have
like in I don't know any like for
example somebody who's like Mexican
American like even then I don't think
being American in some sense like the
privacy from like Mexican like even like
some of the most famous Mexican people
like art is like you guys are like
Selena Selena like she's not she was
like from Texas but she's like everybody
like my grandma like everybody knows
that you don't like um and I think it's
part of just like how much of the quote
unquote like collective experience that
means that like you're mentioning her
language in some sense
barrier but I think parts of being
better means that you can over likens it
overcome Oppo like if I wonder like like
experience more like I don't know if I
wonder like unlike you fight let's say I
want to work in Haiti in the future and
I want to like not be like this like
outsider then I part of it is like me
like in that sense I'm like it's it's
hard that I didn't experience that and I
have to like learn a language but me
it's part of like like just because it's
far too like me two people at the same
time you know it's like I don't know at
the same time like I think it's possible
to like know like to I don't know like
it the fact that it's a berry means that
I think in fact to go back to reality
that you mentioned the fact that they
were the commentary' makers from New
York work do the radiation who grew up
in New York and constantly losing they
didn't speak Creole so therefore doing
patient enough and but now they finally
reaches back to me last week and I want
to continue the interview because I only
asked another question to that you know
if you if you Asian to grab the
desperate how can you learn even clearer
so what what would I suggest and my wife
yes that vintage or patient that brat
actually try to keep the language
actually if the event maybe really grew
up speaking it I can be learning now
even if the adults you see n should be
equal your point is that you can can
always learn yeah it doesn't make like
experience less in the first place but
it's just like if you wanna answer
nothing has it looks like if you want to
like listen to other people like I don't
know if you want like there are sort of
things that you might experience like
it's not the
I just wanted to add Senate on the basis
of language being an experience so the
other day my boyfriend is Haitians and
I'm learning Creole this is for and we
were so that there was a time period and
and you can correct me if I'm wrong
where you shouldn't stopped like Kobus
stopped being a thing for a little bit
which is like Haitian music and now it's
becoming more of a thing and so there's
a lot of like young groups music groups
and the mainly it's like I don't know if
I have an American reference if you know
what my chat is it's like my choppa but
not really it's it's a partner dance
it's I can't agree with that I'm very
much invested in both but there's a lot
of young musician like music groups that
are producing new club music and the way
I've been sort of learning with the
absence of like time to sit down and go
through a book it's just by listening to
these songs and like learning the lyrics
and we went through song and it took us
an hour because there were so many
cultural references that there was no
way like without being Haitian or having
Haitian parents like there was no way
like you would have known what it was I
can't think of one off the top of my
head but like in this whole experience
of like being here and learning about
Haitian experience like there's a
restaurant in Miami called top top
didn't know it topped up with a bus that
was interesting it's a bus and open that
bus you run and jump on to it in the
middle of traffic so so a colleague was
now dead Karen Hale
he said something which is very
beautiful that sound when the lamp when
the language dies out it's like a
library that's burnt down it was a
language the whole library as you
mentioned you know it's a whole set of
experiences that can only really enter
through the language and so you're
examples are taken that Sam but you can
you can enter it you know we might not
master all the
books in the library in fact who can
ever read if it's a big library cannot
read all the books in fact even I myself
i i learned proper to lead a nation free
oh it doesn't end you know and summers I
learned about Proverbs through other
cultures so because there are many
proficient career that I've found also
in Africa in West Africa even in South
Africa and sometimes the meanings of a
slightly different and sometimes you
learn more about a Haitian proverb by
learning it through an African because
oh that sounds familiar then you
understand better what the proverb means
through the African substrate ancestry I
think we should we should stop here for
further discussion are you guys happy
with they have anything else when you
add any other twelve you you just
mention that
[Music]
was an experience they had even any that
that I would have applied that same
definition to identity as well that's
why it was a really glad that I didn't
then answer the first question first
thank you laughter you know I'd be
sitting here reading in and out without
a shirt by cuz confronting the short
answer to that question because if the
notion of authenticity is the kind of
vanity that me there's there's a
tendency to to hide ourselves under
these these labels and we kind of
collect our own power
formation maintenance I guess of
identity and then kind of like what what
she was saying about wanting
take everybody's responsibility and that
reminds me maybe I should bring back
this issue stereotypes and it's a whole
new literature these days and on fixed
mindset versus growth mindset so in a
way I mean given what you just said one
can think of this sort of having
identity that fixed pretty much like
this notion of having fixed mindset
because if you believe in in in fact a
source of research that show that that
if you have a growth mindset mean that
you you be that you can actually learn
new things that you're not you're not
bounded by your fields experience you
know let's go beyond that and that
requires of course practice because
there's nothing that's you know
intelligence that inmates you can always
develop more intelligence now that's a
big break right from previous literature
previous believe that say well you know
you're born with certain amount of
intelligence it's like height and you
cannot go beyond that you know sort of
so the new literature on growth mindset
versus fixed mindset tell us that can
always go beyond what we that were born
with which means that identity should
not be taken as something which is given
once and for can always massage it you
know given particular context and given
particular names right so maybe yeah
sure of course yeah yeah yeah right
right
no but I think Jonathan Jonathan I know
if you remember way back when the retina
give an example of this person with
change who was white and who came to be
black what's the name she she had a job
in the ACLU written that's what that was
you that was you know say that was you
yeah so so even that so even even that
because often skin color it you said
come alone it comes with particular
assumptions about the back skin color
like in Haiti there are people who will
look very white but who are black who
well if it should go back to the saline
to 1805 it's a theory that even if you
polish you need to be black so even so
even back then you know skin color was
not determining those life like most
people are saying like they
like don't accept her identifying as
black so I feel like that supports the
idea that there's something that's right
kind of fixed about it right yeah and
like what you guys are all saying about
like cultural experiences tying in to
certain say like it being a cultural
experience it's not just about like how
like I guess and I wrong or right for
having like attitude like kind of don't
feel like she no I don't feel like she
should be allowed to but I wouldn't want
to accept her being in the place how
dare you when a person who has had no
experience as like an african-american
or like like human like right try to
identify with that you know and like
maybe it would have been different if
she had been a person of color
trying to identify like if she had been
Indian or you know like I'm trying to
think of another really Filipino or
something like trying to identify as
African American maybe I would have been
more lenient but like as a privileged
non person of color when you're crafting
your identity and crafting your
authentic identity what do you look like
right I guess maybe I you're a whole
identity or like authentic identity is
that you're not authentic to anything
but like when you're crafting your
identity what do you draw from is it
like what you authentically feel as or
is it what you like
authentically like have like its ties to
like I have a similar situation where
like like mixed Indian heritage kind of
thing and like when I'm crafting my
Indian American identity do I base it
off like thousand and your based off the
Mauritian do i base it off like north
indian like what what do i do but it's
like do i do I pull from the past or to
pull from like what I feel and like
Rachel Dolezal through the whole thing
was that I feel black whatever that
means but like like where where do you
draw from and then the cinema Lorena
doesn't just apply to like what you
identifies nationality wise or culture
wise because I've been so focused on
being a linguist
that the possibility of having a
capacity and and being having the the
intuition to be a mechanical engineer
never occurred to me but in
participating with like
friends who are like creating projects
like I've I've been the one who to come
up with like ideas that solved problems
and I never thought that would be a
possibility for me because I don't like
math so it's like the identity of being
a linguist was so limiting that I didn't
even know I could do that and I think
that it's like along the same lines of
like are we limiting what we can be by
choosing our identities as well
[Laughter]